if you've been on the Internet at all in
the past two weeks or so you've probably
seen the incredible amount of
allegations of sexual misconduct in
various gaming communities from people
working in game development and
publishing to twitch streamers to
eSports competitors and commentators
hundreds of people have been accused of
sexual harassment assault or in some
cases even worse things but one
community in particular has seen a truly
insane amount of allegations at last
count according to a thread on the Super
Smash Bros reddit over a hundred people
in the Smash Bros competitive community
have been accused of sexual misconduct
and that number has a lot of people
asking the same question how did the
smash scene let this happen
okay so if you haven't seen the
allegations or you've been purposefully
avoiding them for your own mental health
there's been a truly staggering amount
of allegations that talk Super Smash
Bros players and personalities have been
involved in sexual misconduct as a
warning this story deals with sexual
assault and some of the languages and
these statements can be pretty graphic
if that's something that upsets you or
triggers traumatic memories don't watch
any further many top players and
personalities in the smash community
have been accused of a wide variety of
unsavory and often illegal acts the
allegations run the gamut from sending
sexually charged messages to unwilling
recipients to having sex with minors and
before we talk about why this all
happened and where the community goes
from here I'd like to take a second to
amplify a few of the allegations so you
can understand just how serious some of
these accusations are we did a video
earlier this week about many of the
allegations in the wider streaming in
eSports communities and we touched on a
few of the stories you're gonna hear in
this video in particular we spoke about
the allegations against Gonzales 0ba
Rios who is accused of sending sexually
charged messages to an underage girl and
sexually harassing Jacqueline gho a
popular artist in a smash community
while the two were living in the same
house most people would say that the
first person to come forward with
allegations in the smash community over
the past few weeks was Troy Pepe wells
he released a twit longer on July 1st in
which he detailed his relationship with
cinnamon senpai Dunson a popular smash
commentator and puppies twit longer P
alleges that senpai initiated a sexual
relationship with him when he was just
14 years old and she was 24 pepe alleges
that at a post tournament party senpai
who Pepe says was drunk at the time
tackled him to the ground and began
making out with him Popeye alleges that
she continued to have a sexual
relationship with him despite knowing
his age at the time and while they never
had sexual intercourse they did have
oral sex
Pepe also alleges that senpai made him
delete facebook messages between the two
of them about their relationship and
that she didn't let him tell anyone
about their relationship senpai has not
made a statement of her own and has been
inactive on Twitter since the day before
Popeye made his allegation
in addition to that tournament organizer
2g gaming has banned senpai from all
future events then she came out and
denied it then he came out denied it and
then out of nowhere nah this [ __ ] is
true and she's not saying nothing
because there's there's no defense to
this I don't really I don't see any way
that she's going to be able to slide
back from this it's been getting talked
about for like the last four years and
we keep sliding on the table and sliding
on the table and sliding on the table so
I guess but they finally got old enough
to realize that like you know this [ __ ]
is not okay after a puppy made his
statement many more people in this mass
community came forward with allegations
of their own
as a sidenote it's going to be genuinely
impossible to catalog every single
allegation made in the smash community
in this video so we're gonna focus on
just talking about the ones made against
some of the biggest names in the scene
but know that there are more allegations
out there and I urge you to read them
one of the biggest names accused of
sexual misconduct in the smash community
was popular commentator dear on the one
main grant on July 2nd a twitter user
with the username Kati dominate posted a
twit longer in which she accused D one
of raping her during a tournament in
2016 in her allegation Kati dominate
says that on her 18th birthday she
attended a post tournament party with
notable smash pro gypsies MV Deana groan
she says that she was very drunk and D
one asked her to dance before asking her
to follow him in her statement she says
the next moment that I remember I'm
somehow having sex with D one full
penetrative sex and the next flash that
I remember vomiting everywhere profusely
sick alcohol and a blood glucose level
probably in the 700s I was terrified
I don't remember kissing him getting
undressed none of that but I was naked
and vomiting and suddenly I then black
out completely d1 released a twit longer
apology to Katy dominate in which he
says he was very drunk that night and
does not remember what happened after D
1 put out his statement an anonymous
woman came forward with allegations that
around her own 18th birthday d1 bought
her drinks and quote coerced her into
having sexual relations d1 has been
inactive on Twitter since July 2nd among
the most notable pros accused of sexual
misconduct was Nairobi nairo Quezada
also on July 2nd former pro player
Zachary captain
Klaus came forward with allegations that
he had oral sex with nairo when Zach was
15 and naira was 20 captain Zach
released screenshots of a discord
conversation from 2017 with an anonymous
third party in which he recounts the
experience he also includes screenshots
of PayPal receipts for money sent to him
by Nero's brother and a Jeremy toga who
captain Zach alleges is an alternate
account set up by naira captain Zach
alleges that nairo and his brother sent
him that money as a reward for
continuing to not speak about what
happened between the two of them in a
statement captain Zach says I was told
that by doing my part by not telling
anyone about our relations I'd receive
financial help from him the first two
thousand dollars I was sent was equal to
the amount I would have received from my
sponsorship had I not been dropped
notably captain Zach is currently banned
from any tournaments after it came to
light that he was blackmailing fellow
smash player Elliot ally best en
carrozza or yarsa by asking him to throw
important matches under threat that
captain Zach would reveal their
relationship which would have occurred
when captain Zach was 16 and Ally was 26
regardless of captain Zach's previous
ban naira released an apology and has
since deactivated most of his social
media accounts he was dropped by his
team NRG esports and was also banned
from all future events by 2g gaming and
those three cases are just a fraction of
the total number of allegations made
against high-ranking members of the
smash community names that you know have
been accused of sexual misconduct and to
be clear I am NOT saying that these
kinds of allegations have only been made
in the smash community people have
alleged sexual misconduct in just about
every competitive gaming community in
the last few weeks from Street Fighter
to speedrunning the difference here is
that the sheer number of allegations in
the smash community is staggering
moderators on the smash Rose subreddit
maintained a thread catalog give you the
allegations of sexual misconduct made
against people in the smash community
and those people's responses and there
were over a hundred entries on that list
that number really begs the question why
does a smash community have so many
allegations of sexual misconduct to be
honest I'm not entirely sure and I don't
know that anyone knows a hundred percent
of why this all occurred but I do have a
few theories so let me float them by you
the first is that smash has
a very young competitive community and
I'm not talking about the top players
here I'm talking about the hundreds of
young children who turn up in droves to
play in tournaments it's not unusual to
see 12 13 and 14 year-olds playing at
smash events competing at a high level
I've been to plenty of smash events and
at 26 years old I often feel like one of
the oldest people in the room and to be
clear that's not necessarily a problem
kids deserve to have a safe competitive
outlet the problem starts when that
competitive outlet isn't as safe as we
thought many top players commentators
and otherwise notable community figures
have been accused of serious sexual
misconduct here and some of them have
even admitted to their wrongdoings why
are there so many big names in smash
being accused these days well one could
argue that survivors in a smash
community feel safer coming forward with
their stories but I don't necessarily
think that's the case I think that the
smash community has a history of putting
its top players on a pedestal they're
literally compared to gods and that's
not necessarily a problem until they
start believing it for a long time in
the smash community top players have
been set above in all kinds of ways they
get to be the ones on stream at major
tournaments and those tournaments will
advertise their attendance ahead of time
to get more and more people to attend
it's not hard to imagine how that kind
of special treatment could get to
someone's head and lead them to abused
the position of power they've been given
obviously many people wield these
responsibilities responsibly but as
these allegations suggest not everyone
does and again the fact that smashes
core player base is so young really does
change things
it turns being irresponsible with your
position of power from something bad and
to something truly immoral so where does
the community go from here how do you
actually stop this from happening again
well throughout this whole process there
has been one group dedicated to getting
things right the super smash bros code
of conduct panel unfortunately they've
received a lot of pushback in the last
few weeks notably the COC panel is
almost entirely anonymous they aren't
bound by any laws of admissible evidence
and they can decide their own standard
of proof on a case by case basis all
this together has led some people
trust them but when you see some of the
harassment that certain survivors have
gotten for coming forward with their
stories you understand why they want to
stay anonymous they are trying to
protect themselves and the survivors who
come to them but importantly the COC
panels decisions are non-binding no
tournament organizer is compelled to
follow them they just make suggestions
for the wire community and that leads to
situations like what recently happened
with captain Zach just before this all
started
Viji boot camp a tournament organizer
and streaming company announced that
they would be letting captain's that
compete in tournaments as they hosted
once again the COC panel recommended an
indefinite ban on captain Zach with a
chance to appeal that ban after five
years quote we believe that one year was
a suitable enough ban regarding the
circumstances surrounding the case
therefore when things open back up he'll
be allowed to participate in our
tournaments please understand that
tournament organizers hold all authority
and power over their own events when it
comes to the code of conduct judgments
any harassment the COC P receives is
completely unwarranted but therein lies
the problem the COC panels defense for
their harsh judgement on captain Zach
was that they had information they
couldn't share publicly that information
could have been these recent allegations
against naira we don't know they did and
they recommended the ban and because
they don't have the authority to enforce
that ban well they can really do is just
ask the community to trust them I think
what we all learned this week is that
the smash community has perhaps put a
little too much trust in top players and
personalities and not enough trust in
groups like the COC panel notably not
all top players have been accused and
many are even using their platforms to
amplify allegations and try to improve
the scenes leffen for example has been
on his stream trying to make the scene a
better place and talk about these
stories but he's just one person he
can't do everything when you're sending
someone to jail for a long time but you
need to be like 99% sure right that
someone did something before you send
them away we are not sending anyone to
jail what we are doing is making them
not go to smash tournaments so they
can't touch and [ __ ] diddle kids
there
we do not need to be 99% sure to be
clear I don't know what the actual next
step forward is it's gonna be a long
time before tournaments open up again
which gives the community a long time to
try to figure out how to make things
better getting rid of alcohol at after
parties especially after parties for
tournaments with minors and attendance
feels like a pretty easy thing to get
rid of but how do you address the fact
that a significant part of your
community is underage how do you address
the fact that a community built on being
skilled at a video game is very often
gonna put the most skilled players on a
pedestal and how do you address the
allegations that those top players have
been protecting each other from these
stories coming out I don't know but I do
know that there are plenty of good
honest innocent people who just want to
have fun and feel safe playing their
favorite game and I think the community
owes it to them to find a way to make
that happen